the holiday season is in full swing but
there is still time to pick up some
holiday must-haves for all your
celebrations and joining us to share
some fun ideas sponsored by tailor-made
Productions is entertaining expert Paul
Zahn welcome back thanks for having me
tis the season right and there's no one
else that I want to go to than you to
give me some tips on what I can get last
minute what what ideas do you have for
us let's get started with some delicious
wine by Dolce wine so this is out of
Napa Valley it is a late Harvest dessert
wine that's absolutely delicious so late
Harvest means that the grates are left
on the vine a little bit longer to
achieve that natural sweetness which we
love this pairs perfectly with
charcuterie could even make a delicious
New Year's Eve cocktail with this it's
like liquid gold I love ideas for wines
because sometimes I get so confused so
that is brilliant I'm definitely gonna
have to grab a bottle that's why I'm
here to help I'm here to help well maybe
you're not into wine maybe you're into
something else what you got for that
tequila lover we have some great picks
from um JCPenney Beauty so we love JC
Penny because they have such great
prices JCPenney Beauty has something for
everyone and what we have here is a
fragrance Vault for her in a fragrance
Vault for him so these have um 20
different fragrances in there and then
also a 20 gift card to JCPenney Beauty
which we love so if you're going to a
New Year's Eve party you can bring this
gift it to gift it to your holiday host
and um we love it because JCPenney's got
you covered for beauty and it keeps it
keeps on giving with that gift card too
that is absolutely brilliant I love that
it does now we have some a delicious
tequila so like I mentioned you're
excited a little ahead of myself but so
this is a patron Al Alto so Alto means
the heights so the Agave that is 100
Blue Agave grown that's used for this is
grown in the highest points in Jalisco
Mexico it's yielding some absolutely
delicious Agave so this is a blend of
extra Anejo Reposado and yejo and it is
an absolutely delicious tequila and this
is Patron's first foray into the
prestige category and if you're like hot
focus on drays there are so many places
in Vegas you can drink this at Cipriani
so have pour yourself some El Alto
Patron and perfect right well not only
that but look at that bottle bottle's
beautiful right beautiful bottle my gosh
I would collect just that I love it all
right what else do you have for us next
up we have a holiday must-have with the
swan a core cam security camera so this
is a game changer this time of year I've
had so many Amazon packages you know
taken from outside my home so this
camera is 100 Wireless it's easy to put
up it's easy to install it pairs with
your phone and you can you know two-way
talk with it so if Grover from next door
is doing his business out front you say
Grover go back home if somebody's
grabbing your Amazon packages you can
tell them to back off
um day and night vision and Swan really
has you covered with their core cam
security camera which I'm obsessed with
this is a must-have for all year for
security now on this one um this is
Wireless setup so it doesn't take
someone coming out to your house to put
it all together no and the wireless
holds up the battery holds like three
months oh my gosh Wireless wow you
really do have all the best ideas can
you tell us how we can find you if we
want more ideas find me on Instagram at
Paul's on he is the best thank you so
much and if you want to check out any of
these items you can go to our website
8newsnow.com and we'll have all the
details for you